So this is our little school room on the farm,
and I really needed something to warm the place up.
This washable rug,
it just makes the room just feel so much more cosy and inviting
while we're doing our school work.
This room is also with the outside dogs hang out.
So this needs to be a washable rug in this room.
I just love how smooth and soft this rug is.
It also has this non slip rubber backing
so that the rug stays in place.
This rug is super easy to clean with a vacuum or a broom.
And of course, after we got done with our school work,
one of the outside dogs decided to pee on the rug.
So first testing to see how easy it is to wash.
This was super easy. This is the extra large size.
It was easy to get into my machine.
It washed well and dried well.
I had the rug put back down now
and it looks even better than it did before.
If you have dogs and kids, this rug is a must.